rita est chanceuse son fils vient la
chercher pour l'emmener chez le coiffeur
elle n'y avait plus depuis le début de
la pandémie à 86 ans elle a survécu à la
vague de coville qui a déferlé au ch et
celle d yvon brunelle où elle habite
grâce entre autres à son fils ian white
ra qui
joue
un bond pour son coeur devant la mort
qui rôdait j'ai parlé sur youtube ça
fait ça nous fait qu'aucun vient d'en
voir partir
son prochain ce zoo
avait été chanceuse merci monde j'ai
seulement lors de la première vague
soixante treize résidents sont morts de
la coved je revois les noms les visages
de ceux qui sont partis puis la douleur
est presque aussi présente que qu'il ya
deux ans et des images qui ne
s'effaceront jamais un matin je savais
qu'avec 4 corbillard en amas de la porte
pour ne pas oublier le 11 mars est
devenu date de commémoration des
victimes de lakovic 19 dans une lettre
françois legault souligne que le québec
a fait ce qu'il fallait pour sauver le
plus de vies possible écrit-il et il se
souvient que les québécois ont tout de
suite compris la gravité de la situation
contrairement à l'an dernier pas de
cérémonie pas deux minutes de silence
seulement des drapeaux en berne je vais
m'en vaincu pourquoi oublier c'est
pourquoi des aînés de l'arrondissement
du sud ouest se sont rassemblés dans un
contexte où le québec assoupli les
mesures sanitaires les changements dans
le traitement des aînés se font toujours
attendre et là on sent que il ya une
oreille qui s'ouvre gens voudraient 2
mais qui a une oreille qui s'ouvre mais
là je veux vendre les résultats de son
côté rita sans que les taux de l'aco
vide se relâche ce qui ouvre la porte à
d'autres beaux moments avec son fils ici
marie josée paquet comme ou radio canada
montréal